bueno como decíamos causa indignación en
varios sectores sobre todo en Ucrania no
que Rusia asuma la presidencia del
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU pero
quisiera preguntarle cambia algo
realmente que Rusia regrese a este cargo
es un problema más de tipo simbólico que
de efectos prácticos
en realidad es como tú dices Santiago es
un problema más simbólico pero los
símbolos también son importantes en
tiempos de guerra y en este caso
significa básicamente que el consejo de
seguridad no va a emitir declaraciones o
tomar decisiones importantes sobre la
guerra contra Ucrania o sobre otros
problemas en el mundo en los que no hay
consenso entre Rusia y los otros
miembros que son algunos no
así que pues no habrá decisiones no
hablar no habrá declaraciones
importantes Durante un mes está de
cierta manera paralizado el consejo Pero
solo con respecto a temas que importan a
Rusia a largo plazo eso puede Resaltar
la necesidad de reformar a la estructura
de las Naciones Unidas y de su consejo
de seguridad que da privilegios miembros
permanentes a algunos países a las
grandes potencias tradicionales como
Rusia Estados Unidos
Reino Unido Francia y China que en
realidad ya no corresponde a la realidad
del mundo contemporáneo eso puede ser un
efecto importante a más largo plazo
hablaba usted yo gente la importancia de
los simbólico No qué implica que el país
que está creciendo a partir de este
primero de abril el consejo de seguridad
de la ONU esté acusado de crímenes de
guerra de hecho recordemos que la Corte
Penal Internacional que no pertenece a
la ONU pero sí fue respaldada por la ONU
emitió una orden de detención contra
Vladimir Putin
sí es verdad cuando Vladimir Putin viaja
a la mayoría de los países miembros del
Consejo de Seguridad no solo a sus Pues
contrapartes con como Estados Unidos
etcétera Pero también por ejemplo a
Brasil que ha señalado que se sienten
obligados legalmente para arrestar a
Vladimir putins ingresa al país es una
situación
Absurda es una situación que es en
realidad una ilustración potente
del
estatus de Rusia hoy en día como estado
esencialmente
criminal por sus actos de genocidio
contra la población en Ucrania y resalta
en realidad el aislamiento en que se
encuentra si recordamos bien la visita
del presidente de China en Rusia tampoco
les dio
a Vladimir Putin la ayuda que
Seguramente pidió
así que
puede Resaltar
esa situación ahora haciendo lo que
fueron los llamados de Ucrania no que
pidió bloquear esta decisión hubiese
sido viable que la ONU hiciera esto y
que no cumpla con este proceso mediante
el cual como decíamos se derrotan las
presidencias de consejo todos los meses
hay antecedentes de un hecho de este
tipo
yo no recuerdo ningún antecedente
tampoco se tampoco Se bloqueó el consejo
de seguridad de la ONU durante el inicio
de la guerra cuando Rusia también era
Era presidente como ya se dijo Así que
Aparentemente los países miembros no
tienen la voluntad para tomar pasos más
decididos lo que Sería posible por
ejemplo Estados Unidos podrían bloquear
físicamente el acceso de delegaciones
rusas o que no tiene antecedente tampoco
que sería realmente una brecha drástica
en el mundo de las relaciones
internacionales contemporáneas pero en
realidad yo no veo esto como una
situación de crisis pero como una imagen
Absurda que va que va a propulsar la
llamada para reformas como evoluciona
esta situación Muchísimas gracias por su
análisis en France 24